[Music]
before we start this video i just wanted
to mention that only 20
of you are subscribed so if you enjoy
the content
please consider subscribing to support
the channel thanks to you guys we're
well on our way
to two hundred thousand hey everyone
welcome to another installment
of harry potter theory in this video
we're going to be continuing on the
subject
of one of my previous videos where i
discussed hogwarts student
casey bell and how she fell victim to a
terrible
cursed object the opal necklace the opal
necklace is actually brought to our
attention
quite early on in the books but the role
that it would play obviously doesn't
become clear
until much later on we first see the
necklace when harry mistakenly enters
borgen and burks
in the year 1992 the sinister necklace
was on display
in the unusual shop complete with a
warning label
do not touch cursed has claimed the
lives of 19 muggle owners to date
after that the necklace isn't discussed
or seen again
that is until the half-blood prince when
draco malfoy decides to use it
for dark deeds the half-blood prince was
sort of the beginning
of draco's real transition to the dark
side where previously he was just sort
of the
archetypal school bully the imprisonment
of his father brought out all sorts of
demons in him
morally he was very much on the fence up
to that point and in the half-blood
prince
he really cements his new path when he
places madame osmeta
under the imperius curse who then places
katie under the imperious curse
when katie finds a package in the girl's
bathroom she knows that she has to take
it to dumbledore
however this package contained none
other than the opal necklace
a cursed magical artifact capable of
causing some serious damage
i mean look what it did to katie at once
katie rose into the air
gracefully her arms outstretched as
though she was about to fly
yet there was something wrong something
eerie her hair whipped her by the fierce
wind
but her eyes were closed and her face
was quite empty of expression
then six feet above the ground katie let
out a terrible scream
her eyes flew open but whatever she
could see whatever she was feeling
was clearly causing her terrible anguish
though the books and films began to
develop a gradual dark undertone earlier
on in the series
this scene really set the bar for the
type of new dark content that we were to
expect for the remainder of the books
and films
katie's body was dragged and thrown
around violently in a vicious display
and dark dark magic was clearly at play
some of the darkest magic
to appear up to that point it made the
cruciato's curse look innocent
and this tells me that not only was it
dark magic but powerful magic
as well now based on the fact that it's
what appears to be
an inanimate object and the fact that in
order to be subjected to its full evil
nature
you need to touch it i immediately began
to form the connection in my mind with
voldemort's horcruxes
as you should know by now horcraxes are
objects in which a dark witch or wizard
is imbued part of their soul
the purpose of which is to make it
difficult for them to be completely
killed
and just like the opal necklace
horcruxes commonly have some sort of
defense mechanism
counter charms jinxes that make them
difficult to even approach
one of the reasons that they have these
defense mechanisms is so that they can't
be destroyed
as they contain a soul fragment from the
original creator
however the counter-charm is just the
first line of defense
as horcruxes are notoriously difficult
to destroy
in fact there are only a few known ways
of destroying them the most notable of
which
involves the basilisk fang or rather the
venom within the basilisks fang
the opal necklace is clearly an old
ancient dark magical artifact
and given its questionable history and
the fact that you can't directly handle
it
i'm sure someone has tried to destroy it
at one point or another
its existence in the half blood prince
however is certainly a testament to its
resilience
and i think that its durability may be
one of the other reasons
that points to it being a horcrux so if
the opal necklace
is a horcrux who did it belong to whose
soul fragment does it contain
i know that when we think of horcruxes
we commonly think of voldemort
but this time and only this time he's
not the man behind this dark magic
however i do have a couple of theories
for who it could be
according to the history books there are
only two known wizards to have completed
the horcrux creation process
voldemort and herpo the fowl the most
obvious answer to this question
would be that this horcrux belongs to
none other than herper the fowl
the ancient dark wizard that hailed from
greece and was known to have created
just one horcrux it's entirely unknown
when herpo walked the earth
but we do know that it was a long long
time ago he is commonly referred to as
one of the earliest known dark wizards
and he devoted his life to producing and
creating some of the worst kinds of
magic imaginable
in fact he is commonly credited as the
original
horcrux creator but is that entirely
true
or was he just the first horcrux creator
that we know about
jk rowling once revealed that over the
course of history
many witches and wizards have tried to
create one in spite of a severe lack of
instruction
from the evil textbooks wizards would
have been looking for ways to do exactly
what voldemort did for
years and some of the ways they would
have tried would have killed them
so i imagine it well they're huge
parallels
splitting the atom would be a very good
parallel in our world i do imagine that
other people are going to have tried
i think it'd be naive not to think that
people have been trying for a long time
and thought they succeeded and hadn't or
else made themselves or killed
themselves in the attempt
it's such a dangerous thing to do so
what does this tell us
to me this suggests that there just may
have been someone out there
that produced one and never took credit
for it after all
if the idea of producing a horcrux is
self-preservation
why would you want to boast about it and
bring it to everyone's attention
there is actually one other wizard that
comes to my mind when considering who
this potential horcrux
may have belonged to and that is a
christus like herpo
a christus is another of the famed dark
wizards of history
though he isn't commonly associated with
horcruxes he is thought to be the
original creator
of something even more sinister the
dementors
very little is known about acrystus
other than the fact that he was alive
during the 15th century that he was a
practitioner of some of the worst kinds
of dark magic
imaginable he was the original
inhabitant of the island of azkaban
before it became the prison and it was
there that he conducted all sorts of
twisted dark arts experiments
he placed concealment charms on the
island which hid its location
and then lured mughal sailors there
torturing and murdering them
it was on the island of azkaban that
christus who was already crazy
completely lost his mind and given his
isolation
aptitude for dark magic and endless test
subjects
i think there's a case to be made for
chrysdus making horcrux of his own
furthermore
a crisis is credited as having created
the dementors
evil soul-sucking creatures that leave
you as just a shell of a person
after they're done with you it only
seems fitting that a crisdus
whose dark magic revolved around
properties of the soul would have pushed
the limits and embedded his own soul
in some kind of object if it was indeed
herpo or a christus
then that would mean that they're still
alive which is creepy to think about
and if it was someone else all together
then it just means that there's a dark
wizard out there
who doesn't want to take credit for
producing it i mean all of this assuming
the opal necklace actually is a horcrux
what do you guys think was it herpo a
christus
or some other dark wizard altogether is
the opal necklace
horcrux let me know down in the comment
section below
until next time you're a wizard harry
you